bonjour et bienvenue sur 9 7 4 tv dans
ce cadre exceptionnel qui est le théâtre
plein air de saint-gilles
aujourd'hui nous allons à la rencontre
d'artistes est précisément de musiciens
qui vont faire vivre le festival total
jazz rencontre jouée à porter pour jour
bonjour et bienvenue ya venus
s'installer alors fabulateur de tuer ce
qu'il y avait dans ces îles à l'école de
musique actuelle c'est beau séjour de
sanary oui travaille beaucoup avec les
jeunes notamment les collections des
musées à voile à leur apprendre ce que
c'est le sial
bah oui en fait c'est pour le faire
découvrir qu'est ce que c'est que le gaz
c'est une musique qui improvise et c'est
pas la musique comme les jeunes actuels
il est en ce moment c'est le maître
guizhou cetera et cetera le départ
d'andy là on va les faire découvrir
qu'est ce que c'est une improvisation
comment aborder l'improvisation
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un cocktail de
jazz
voilà toute cette histoire parce qu'il
faut savoir que le jazz a appuyé de
recettes maintenant parce que voilà et
dont je vous l ai toujours joué mais pas
c'est diffusé auprès des jeunes ça reste
quand même musique de je dirais pas de
vieux mais quand on leur parle de jazz
ils voient ça comme une musique elle que
lointaine sexy mais en fait non tout le
monde peut faire du casse comment fait
on alors moins souvent ce que moi j'ai
fait par exemple pour un jeune qui a
huit ans entre s'étend du temps à
l'école beauséjour
quand je commence à aborder un thème de
jazz bien sûr il ya plusieurs méthodes
plusieurs façons d'aborder d'aborder par
un blues très simple moi j'avais souvent
par une chanson française que tous les
jeunes connaissent même les moins jeunes
et les plus gay s'est scellée chanson u
comme
il était un petit navire ou larry david
lalalalalalalalala à partir de là il
fois que le thème mise en place je le
dis mais maintenant vous allez improvisé
là une façon d'improviser le ludique ils
vont taper que ceux des notes blanches à
partir de là ça va venir naturellement
c'est à dire que je rappe par un thème
de jazz parce que ça va être dur c'est
le trop plein d harmonie donc je
commence comme ça une fois qu'ils y
prennent goût
meza mais on va faire un petit blues
voient mon trois accords et de la après
je le développe au fur et à mesure ça se
prépare et moi ça peut venir prendre un
an d en or - on les a enfin moi j'essaie
donc voilà on veut la voir et pour les
ados je prends souvent une musique très
connu jean rue jean paul parent que les
ados équipe beaucoup et de la com sur
les accords très simple je les fais
people donc là à monsieur je peux pas l
air que j'improvise mais oui on peut
improviser dans une musique actuelle que
ces people et du coup ça ça t'a permis
de découvrir on va dire peut-être de
futurs jeunes talents ben au fait quand
on a fait l'année dernière déjà il ya
deux je crois se sont inscrits à l'école
sainte-marie d'après qu'en dira-t-on
et parce qu'ils ont aimé le jazz c'était
c'était des lycéens et donc du coup ben
en fait nous ont ce mois-là turine parce
qu'il faut savoir du rang st je suis pas
seule sur laquelle notre un autre
notre qu'alice a pas souri mitchell et
donc on sensibilise les gens sébacées
jeanne mas et on l'emmène vers le vert
le jazz c'est ça qui aimait parce que
selon garneau jazz band ou et c est ça
ne perdure pas il faut que ça ce qui
revient dans le temps que ça se perpétue
au fait on comprend bien aussi c'est un
partage saint martin juneau qu'on peut
avoir avec des jeunes dont qui on
revient sur le festival qui est aussi un
moment de partage d'échangé on va dire à
qui on est plus que les lyonnais
oui c est quoi qu'on regarde ce qui va
le total jazz
alors c'est total chazelas l'idéaliste
la préhistoire que je le fais et je vais
juste me s'allongera historique d'abord
avant de dire aux gens envie de jouer
bien sûr tout le monde a envie de jouer
lors que ce soit même l'international
j'ai envie de jouer là parce que c'est
un endroit pas même pendant 40 ans
existe on a vu ça voilà tous les tous
les grands ou pas c'est la passant par
lequel on va s'emparer et c est moi lors
du festival 2013
à saint gilles c'est là où j'ai
rencontré pascal montrouge et je lui ai
dit j'aimerais bien passer là et c'est
pour ça l'idée lui est venue de monter
un couac sur piano volcanique c'est
comme ça j'ai pu jouer là pour une
première fois devant une horrible mot
thüringe est où et pour moi c'était
vraiment un événement de la de là on a
joué dans les lycées ça s'est très bien
passé et cette année il nous a remis
dans les collèges cette fois ci donc on
fait six collèges sur sur le programme
tous les collèges sont mentionnés sur la
fin donc on va jouer la table d'ailleurs
commence le mercredi prochain 13 14 je
croyais à 7,8 et après pour finir le 24
je joue avec genre de m c'est un
guitariste et là on fait un saint jean
de séga-maloya jazz rapporte donc laura
et il y aura les gens club med sera bien
à peyremale à la basse et il y aura
laurent ladauge à la trique et moi-même
au clavier donc ça c'est la fois
franco-chinoise 24 d'accord et le seul
coup d'état que je voulais souligner
cette année je trouve justement que le
propre que le
que l'affiché bien fait c'est qu'on
passe dans la rue où on peut voir enfin
à tiens c'est ça parce que d'habitude on
voi internationaux et lot il faut
regarder petit à anor déjà pas trop tard
on a sûrement de très bon article
il faut lui montrer il nous faut les
montrer et même ça c'est propos d'autres
artistes du futur les jeunes savent
allait permettre d'être attirés sont là
on nous assure faire l'effort oui c'est
ça je trouvais
wonderful